[Música]
hola bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica 7 días este es un magazine 100%
dedicado al continente africano mi
nombre es andrés meza muños y estos son
nuestros titulares el primer ministro de
etiopía aviv ahmet tomó posesión para un
nuevo período esto bajo la sombra del
conflicto armado en la región de tigre
que se expande hacia otras zonas del
país y que aumenta el número de
desplazados se estima que unas 52
millones de personas requieren de
asistencia urgente la organización
mundial de la salud pidió perdón ante
los reportes de más de 80 casos de
abusos sexuales durante la emergencia de
ébola en la república democrática del
congo ya que 21 de los 83 perpetradores
pertenecían a la o ms después de la
caída de los precios del petróleo en
2016 y una crisis económica agravada por
la pandemia de kobe 19 nigeria busca
impulsar su economía a través del aceite
de palma el cual fue el principal
productor mundial en la década de 1960
pero la industria señalada de contribuir
a la deforestación
empezamos en etiopía el primer ministro
hábil me tomo posesión para un mandato
de cinco años luego de que su partido
ganara las cuestionadas elecciones del
pasado mes de julio durante su
investidura el mandatario culpó a los
rebeldes de la región de tigre por el
conflicto que estalló hace diez meses y
que ha ensombrecido su mandato mientras
se expande a otras regiones vecinas e
incrementa el número de desplazados
hace unos días el gobierno expulsó a
siete trabajadores de naciones unidas-
que hicieron sonar las alarmas sobre el
bloqueo en el acceso de ayuda
humanitaria en tigre acusándolos de
inmiscuirse en los asuntos internos del
país el hecho provocó la condena de la
onu que insistió en que unas 52 millones
de personas en tigre requieren de
asistencia urgente
la hambruna el enemigo silencioso que
avanza en el conflicto del tigre según
el programa mundial de alimentos casi 7
millones de personas afrontan una crisis
de hambre mientras que la onu advirtió
de la necesidad de acercar ayuda al
norte de etiopía tanto con alimentos
como con otros insumos
[Música]
tenemos un número muy alto de personas
que necesitan ayuda urgente en tigre he
hecho 52 millones de personas requieren
asistencia urgente virginie of systems
el conflicto que estalló hace casi un
año entre el gobierno etíope y el frente
popular de liberación de tigre ahora se
está expandiendo a las vecinas regiones
de amhara y a farc a medida que los
rebeldes tigrillos intentan avanzar en
esas áreas se frente al retiro del
ejército etíope en lanzar a las fuerzas
tigrillas han sido acusadas del
asesinato de cientos de civiles algunos
de los cuales se han sumado a las
milicias locales en los combates en el
pequeño poblado de chena los residentes
estuvieron que abandonar sus hogares
entraron tan pronto como se fue el
ejército en cuanto ingresaron comenzaron
a masacrar a nuestros familiares
tenemos que huir ya no tenemos una casa
aquí nuestra vivienda fue atacada con
artillería pesada y el humberto las
autoridades etíopes estiman que unas 450
mil personas han sido desplazadas por
los combates en ankara y a farc y más de
2 millones debieron huir de sus hogares
desde el inicio del conflicto en tigre
una comisión encargada por la
organización mundial de la salud desveló
que más de 80 mujeres fueron abusadas
sexualmente durante la emergencia de
ébola en la república democrática del
congo los hechos se produjeron entre
2018 y 2020 y 21 de los 83 perpetradores
pertenecían a la organización mundial de
la salud los altos mandos de la
organización se declararon horrorizados
por los hallazgos este es un informe de
luís muñoz
estaban para ayudar pero aprovecharon la
confianza para abusar una comisión
independiente encargada por la
organización mundial de la salud detectó
83 presuntos perpetradores de abuso
sexual entre 2018 y 2020 los hechos
ocurrieron durante la respuesta de la
agencia de la salud de la onu a un brote
de ébola en la república democrática del
congo 21 de los implicados eran
trabajadores de la o ms 4 todavía
trabajaban para el organismo camps soria
lo siento amor y formato están lamento
lo que hicieron las personas empleadas
en la o ms para servir y proteger
lamentó el sufrimiento continuo que esos
hechos han causado cáncer y ford y
ongoing shaffer in this events must code
empleos a cambio de relaciones sexuales
nueve posibles violaciones y extorsiones
a mujeres abusadas para que aportaran
tras el informe la oms se prometió
actuar de inmediato con apoyo protección
y justicia para víctimas y
sobrevivientes
abordando las fallas de gestión y
personal de la organización y con una
reforma estructural y cultural
en lado ms estamos realmente conmovidos
horrorizados y desconsolados por los
resultados de la investigación cuál en
los últimos años se han sucedido las
investigaciones que desvelan que altos
mandos de la ms fueron informados de
estas denuncias además de no haber
conseguido detener el acoso habrían
ascendido a uno de los responsables es
el mayor caso de delitos sexuales para
una agencia de la onu desde los cascos
azules acusados de abusar más de dos mil
mujeres en haití entre 2004 y 2017 vamos
a argelia que se rozó espacio aéreo a
los aviones militares franceses marcando
el peor roce entre los dos países en
varios años
argel retiró a su embajador de parís
citando comentarios atribuidos al
presidente manuel quien se habría
referido al gobierno argelino como un
sistema político militar que ha
reescrito la historia de la colonización
basándose en el odio a francia
los aviones de guerra franceses ya no
pueden utilizar el espacio aéreo de
argelia aunque no se ha hecho ningún
anuncio oficial para ir recibió el
mensaje después de que rechazaran a dos
de sus aviones francia usaba la ruta
para enviar aeronaves desde y hacia la
región del sahel donde el 5000 de sus
efectivos ayudan a los aliados
regionales a luchar contra los
yihadistas este es el último movimiento
de la creciente tensión diplomática
entre francia y argelia que ha empeorado
tras las declaraciones de macrón citadas
por el diario le monde el sábado según
el artículo el líder francés criticó el
sistema político militar de argelia por
reescribir la historia basándose en su
odio a francia la nación argelina post
1962 ha vivido de la idea de que francia
es el problema desde su independencia la
élite gobernante argelina está compuesta
por militares de la guerra de liberación
de los años 50
por su parte macrón llegó a cuestionar
que la nación existiera antes de ser
colonizada por francia
sostuvo que el sistema se había
debilitado debido al movimiento
prodemocrático que derrocó al presidente
abdelaziz buteflika como respuesta a
argelia retiró a su embajador de parís y
acusó a macrón de interferir en asuntos
internos ante esta situación inaceptable
que han dejado estas declaraciones
irresponsables consigo el presidente de
la república decidió llamar
inmediatamente a consultas al embajador
de argelia en la república francesa la
tensión y aire latente entre ambas
naciones a raíz de la decisión de parís
de reducir en los visados a ciudadanos
de argelia marruecos y túnez pasamos a
guinea el coronel mamady don bulla quien
encabezó el golpe militar contra el
presidente alpha condé tomó juramento
como mandatario interino no voy a
liderar a un período de transición que
no está especificado y durante el cual
dijo combatir a la corrupción se
redactará una nueva constitución se
reformará el sistema electoral y se
organizaran elecciones aunque aún no se
sabe cuándo se llevarán a cabo estos
comicios pero ha dejado claro que los
miembros de la junta militar no podrán
postularse la comunidad económica de
estados de áfrica occidental ha
congelado activos estos impuestos
prohibiciones de viaje- a la junta con
la esperanza de alertar o de alentar un
rápido retorno a la democracia
después de la caída de los precios del
petróleo en 2016 una crisis económica
agravada por la pandemia de kobe 19
nigeria busca diversificar su economía y
crear empleos a través del aceite de
palma el cual fue el principal productor
mundial en la década de 1960 el gobierno
está invirtiendo en el que una vez fue
un sector próspero pero los pequeños
agricultores señalan que se ven
excluidos informe de amal benotman
palmeras hasta donde alcanza la vista en
el estado nigeriano de ello las
plantaciones cubren más de 33 mil
hectáreas de terreno fueron financiadas
en parte por un préstamo de 33 millones
de dólares otorgado por el gobierno
nuestra empresa puede obtener un
préstamo del banco central de ingeniería
en el marco de los préstamos concedidos
a las empresas agrícolas eso fue
suficiente para conseguir dinero
claramente hemos ayudado a financiar
nuestra expansión y tensión y otros
mayor productor de petróleo de áfrica
nigeria ha estado envuelto desde la
caída de los precios del combustible con
una crisis económica últimamente
agravada por la pandemia de cody 19 el
país decidió entonces diversificar su
economía y apostar por la producción de
aceite de palma pero los pequeños
productores dicen que están excluidos
del plano
nica 8 cultiva una pequeña plantación en
el estado de akwá ibom en el sur de
nigeria tiene ahora 30 empleados frente
a los 5 que tenía cuando empezó pero
necesita más dinero para seguir
cultivando sus tierras
central sólo le escuchamos en las
noticias antes estaba en un sindicato
progresista
porque recién éramos formulario
hiciéramos lo que hiciéramos al fin el
préstamo una banca no se os no llega a
los verdaderos agricultores locales ese
es el problema al que nos enfrentamos
radio pública ofrece aunque sus
partidarios afirman que ayuda al
desarrollo local y a la creación de
empleo la industria del aceite de palma
ha sido objeto de fuertes críticas
los defensores de medio ambiente entre
otros dicen que contribuye a la
deforestación y a la desaparición de
tierras comunitarias el presidente de
túnez caixa ayer nombró a la primera
mujer en el cargo de primer ministro en
la historia del país más la budín es
también la primera mujer que ocupa este
cargo en el mundo árabe su nombramiento
llega dos meses después de que el
presidente suspendiera el parlamento y
destituyera al primer ministro ahora
tendrá la misión de formar gobierno para
poner fin a la crisis política pero hay
dudas sobre cuánto poder tendrá wood en
debido a las recientes acciones del
presidente que entre otras medidas se
dio el poder de gobernar por decreto
seguimos hablando de mujeres después de
una crisis electoral y los
enfrentamientos entre las fuerzas
armadas y grupos rebeldes la actividad
económica en la capital de república
centroafricana empieza a reanudarse con
la llegada de nuevos inversores a la
ciudad y a la construcción de nuevas
obras en este país las desigualdades de
género siguen estando profundamente
arraigadas especialmente en esta
industria pero ahora algunas mujeres
están decididas a encontrar un lugar en
la parte superior del andamio
ladrillo a ladrillo la capital de la
república centroafricana se está
renovando después de décadas de
inestabilidad las obras de construcción
vuelven a florecer en todo banguí
ejecutadas y administradas por nuevos
trabajadores
tiene 23 años es una de las pocas
ingenieras civiles del país ella dice
que tiene que demostrar sus habilidades
en el trabajo todos los días
cuando eres una chica dar órdenes aquí a
los trabajadores es complicado los
hombres no lo soportan pero ese es el
trabajo que
tienen que seguir la línea para que el
proyecto avanza 0 x es completar
proyectos y también transmitir
conocimientos a los futuros ingenieros e
body comparte su pasión con su becaria
guiando a su aprendiz hacia el éxito en
una industria que está floreciendo en su
país ella es la directora que le dio su
gran oportunidad
jiang yu es la gerente de una de las
mayores empresas constructoras del país
que está detrás de este proyecto de 4
millones de euros
hay mujeres excelentes en el país con
muchas habilidades tratamos de apoyarnos
en china- decimos que las mujeres
sostienen la mitad del cielo deberíamos
estar haciendo todo
en el mismo barrio en el tercer piso de
un edificio que pronto tendrá cinco
conocemos a leonel paguen hace seis años
que trabaja en chatarra un trabajo que
le permite alimentar a su familia
note que pocas mujeres hacían este
trabajo así que decidí aprender en la
capacitación y ahora soy una trabajadora
calificada las mujeres deben atreverse y
armarse de valor para desarrollar el
país evo de jennifer y lionel esta nueva
generación de constructoras sigue siendo
una excepción de la república
centroafricana uno de los peores países
del mundo en términos de igualdad de
género según naciones unidas hasta que
áfrica siete días recuerden que poder
encontrar este u otro episodio de
nuestro programa en nuestra página web
www puntos france24 puntocom
[Música]